I know you're a fan of Joseph Campbell
the hero's journey yeah and most people
are I there's not really any criticism
yes sir well I think like I learned so
much from Joseph Campbell I like I
discovered him pretty young I was like
maybe 16 or 17 when I started reading
him and I was you know amazed by it and
of course the thing that was nice about
him was he was kind of a foray into
young and like you know the theory of
archetypes and things like that so it
was you know it's it well well
Campbell's dense you know it's it's a
totally different thing to delve into
Jung and Freud and all those things and
what a part of the issue like I know
that like for example the hero and the
hero's journey and people regard the
hero is like one of the the central
architects of the character but a this I
think Joseph Campbell illuminated
certain insights in the story that I
that were incredibly helpful but I don't
think it's enough of a complete theory
and I plan on doing a video about this
later to kind of get more specific but
just to give a teaser I mean ultimately
you know when we look at a hero here is
a very specific it's a specific kind of
character and so I tend to refer to
things as a protagonist versus a hero a
hero's is someone that exhibits certain
virtues and values that are considered
and ideal and usually the story is about
them testing their mettle but a story
can be so much more than just a kind of
vulgar propaganda on on exhibiting ideal
virtues and that's why I like the hero's
journey I think is brilliant it's
fantastic one thing that I liked about
Joseph Campbell was that he was
exploring the way the universality of
certain story structures but I don't
think it's enough of a complete paradigm
because when we look at why we tell
stories it doesn't quite account for the
initiation of
tribe or into the tribe and that's
that's what I think is that's something
that's very fascinating to me is that
like my next video is about tribalism
actually I'm in the process of talking
about tribalism I'd set up the
relationship between a really religion
and story in one video I'm going to tie
into tribalism and I'm defining
tribalism in a very specific way we're
going to go into the kind of biological
imperatives that inform tribalism but
basically I and this little teaser but I
find groups there are different groups
of people that define themselves
according to what their objectives are
so for example a community is a group of
people with a common interest a movement
is a group of people with a common cause
a tribe is a group of people with a
common enemy hmm so and they have very
very different ways of functioning if
you have an enemy that creates a kind of
usually creates a kind of loyalty
becomes very important it's a virtue
it's a virtue within a tribe within a
community of broad open interests you
don't necessarily need loyalty in order
to function you can just have voluntary
interactions with tribalism because it
defines itself primarily by its enemy
and it presents presents that as a
threat and therefore hierarchy becomes
very important and a lot of stories
throughout most of history most of the
history of humanity were designed to
help create those hierarchies so because
most tribes were surviving in the
context of a lot of a lot of constant
threat perpetual threat which means they
had to live in very rigid communities or
really rigid groups of people so the
narratives and the stories they would
tell were always about hero structures
they were they're designed to help
people incorporate these value
in these virtues as vital to survival
and so because of that the this hero's
journey was ultimately a kind of
propaganda because it was designed to to
drive people's behavior and value system
to be subject and loyal to the tribe and
that's why I think stories that are more
engaged in moral ambiguity have much
more interesting things that to tell
because they're not just interested in
imposing or propagating specific narrow
values that emphasize loyalty but
instead will actually explore the nature
of the human condition and that's what I
think is a much more interesting thing
if we can understand the way that story
is a kind of exploration of values
rather than just a propagation of values
then I think we actually have more
meaningful discourse in an understanding
story and in humanity
you